[Musik]
hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
wir sprechen hier heute auch über das
Ende des Nato-Gipfels der hat gestern
und heute in Vilnius stattgefunden und
über den Berichten wir ja schon in die
vergangenen zwei Tage lasst uns direkt
mal auf die Bilder des heutigen Tages
schauen am letzten Tag des Nato-Gipfels
in Litauen hat auch erstmals der neue
NATO Ukraine Rat getagt den wir da
gerade sehen und obwohl die NATO die
Ukraine nicht in das Bündnis eingeladen
hatte sie künftig enger mit Kiew
zusammenarbeiten und dazu gibt's jetzt
diesen Rat der soll sich viermal im Jahr
treffen das ist ein neues Gremium in dem
die Ukraine auch gleichberechtigter
Partner ist ja hier sind wir Bilder vom
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski der
aber wohl letztendlich lieber im NATO
Bündnis sitzen würde ja das ist jetzt
das Ergebnis nach zwei Tagen NATO gibt
vorerst kein NATO-Beitritt für die
Ukraine und wir wollen deswegen heute
diskutieren ob der NATO aktuell der Mut
fehlt und wie immer mache ich das nicht
alleine sondern ich habe mir Gäste
eingeladen zum einen den ehemaligen
us-generalleutnant Ben Hodges und meinen
zdf-korrespondenten Ulf Röller der für
uns live in Vilnius ist und wie immer
möchten wir das ganze auch mit euch da
draußen diskutieren habt ihr Fragen zum
Thema oder vielleicht auch Meinungen die
ihr mit uns und der Community teilen
wollt dann tut das wie immer gerne
einfach hier im Youtube Chat oder per
Mail an die Mail-Adresse die ihr gerade
eingeblendet seht und jetzt gucken wir
aber erstmal auf unseren ersten
Gesprächspartner den ehemaligen
US-General Leutnant bin und den stellen
wir euch jetzt mal kurz vor
tschüss general Leutnant ad der US-Armee
geborene Quincy Florida Alter 65
seine Auslandseinsätze führen ihn ab den
80er Jahren unter anderem nach
Deutschland Afghanistan und in den Irak
von 2014 an ist der Oberkommandierender
der
us-landstreitkräfte für Europa und die
Gebiete der Ex sowjet-staaten
einschließlich Russland schon 2015 also
nach der Krim Annexion durch Russland
und angesichts der Kämpfe zwischen der
ukrainischen Armee mit prorussischen
Separatisten vermutet Rogers Russland
breite sich auf einen Krieg vor der
sechs Jahre später stattfinden könnte
seit 2017 sein Ruhestand der keiner ist
denn Rogers beschäftigt sich weiter mit
Geopolitik und militärischer Sicherheit
und steht mit seiner Expertise beratend
zur Verfügung
ja und mit seiner Expertise ist er jetzt
live
jetzt direkt auch
zugeschaltet schönen guten Abend
guten Abend danke
was hatten Sie denn im Vorfeld von
diesen zweitägigen Gipfel erwartet und
was ist letztendlich für sie dabei
rumgekommen was ist ihre Summe nach
diesen zwei Tagen
ich hatte wie immer erwartet dass die
Priorität des Gipfels Einigkeit sein
würde dass die NATO-Mitglieder deutlich
machen würden dass auch wenn es
Unterschiede bei politischen
Entscheidung gibt dass die NATO
zueinander steht und ganz fest zu
unserer gemeinsamen Sicherheit steht und
die das Bündnis hat das wieder erreicht
aber ich muss sagen ich war etwas
enttäuscht weil die Allianz nicht
willens war eine konkrete Einladung an
die Ukraine zu operieren um der Natur
beizutreten es gibt ein stärkeres Gefühl
der Unterstützung für die ukratzt hier
zuvor
seitdem bukareester Gipfel 2018 aber
vielleicht war es wegen der das
Widerstands von den USA und Deutschland
vielleicht konnte deswegen das Bündnis
kein konkreteres also keine konkrete
Abklärung abgeben zum Beitritt der
Ukraine das ist so meine Zusammenfassung
ja das zur ersten Zusammenfassung wir
sprechen mit Herrn hat jetzt gleich noch
weiter über Sicherheitsgarantien der G7
über weitere militärische Unterstützung
und über die Lage in der Ukraine da
freue ich mich drauf ich würde aber
vorher einmal mit euch auf die zwei Tage
Gipfel gucken die hat nämlich
ZDF-Korrespondent ultra einmal für uns
zusammengefasst
silensky wartet auf den Bundeskanzler
und wirkt angespannt der Gipfel hat ihm
keine Einladung zum NATO-Beitritt
ausgesprochen auch Scholz war gegen eine
solche Garantie stattdessen hat der
Kanzler ein militärpaket für die Ukraine
mitgebracht im Wert von fast 700
Millionen Euro in der Pressekonferenz
zieht silenski eine gemischte
gipfelbilanz
die Ergebnisse des Gipfels sind
zufriedenstellend aber hätten wir eine
Einladung zum NATO-Beitritt bekommen
wäre der Gipfel perfekt
danach ein herzlicher Empfang für den
ukrainischen Präsidenten
es ist schön Dich bei uns zu haben der
NATO Ukraine Rat wird gegründet ein
neues Gremium in dem die Ukraine
gleichberechtigtes Mitglied ist
unsere Entscheidung hat die Ukraine
näher an die NATO herangerückt
der Gipfel voller Symbolik die G7
Staaten geben der Ukraine Zusicherungen
das Land bis zum NATO-Beitritt
beschützen zu wollen sprich dauerhafte
Waffenlieferungen aber die G7 Staaten
stellen keine eigenen Truppen außerdem
muss die Ukraine die Details noch mit
den einzelnen Ländern vereinbaren es
geht um
Sicherheitspartnerschaft die dringend
notwendig ist und die es möglich macht
dass die Staaten die das Unterzeichnen
dann im konkreten Ihre Beiträge in der
aktuellen Situation weiter präzisieren
aber das auch einbetten in eine
längerfristige Strategie auf die sich
die Ukraine dann auch verlassen kann
dieses Sicherheit zu sagen scheinen den
ukrainischen Präsidenten ein wenig mit
dem Gipfel zu versöhnen
ja und in den letzten Zügen dieses
Gipfels ist mir jetzt ultra auch direkt
zugeschaltet hallo guten Abend schön
dass du bei uns bist
gerne sehr gerne wir haben es ja gerade
in deinem Stück gesehensky sprach jetzt
von einem zufriedenstellenden Gipfel
gestern hat er noch getwittert diese
gewisse Planlosigkeit für den
NATO-Beitritt sei Zitat absurd und
beispiellos kannst du uns erklären woher
dieser Sinneswandel von selenski jetzt
kommt
ich glaube er ist Profi er muss wissen
wie die Machtverhältnisse in der NATO
sind und er muss wissen und das weiß er
auch dass eben wenn die Amerikaner ihm
diese
nato-beitrittsgarantie nicht geben
wollen wenn die Deutschen das nicht
wollen dann sind das zwei sehr sehr
mächtige Länder es war noch nicht die
einzigen Länder aber es waren die sehr
mächtigen und wichtigsten Länder dass
dann selenski nichts machen kann ich
glaube schon er kam mir wie man so schön
sagen würde mit einem dicken Hals Herr
er war ziemlich sauer er bräuchte
eigentlich diese nato-garantie die hätte
er mit nach Hause nehmen können auch als
Motivation für die Truppe aber man hat
sie ihm eben nicht gegeben aus sehr ja
für die Amerikaner nachvollziehbaren
Gründen man hat Angst dass man sich dazu
sehr verpflichtet und man sagt wir
wissen nicht wie der Krieg aus geht und
wenn man auch hinter der vorgehalten hat
hier auch hört dass nicht sicher ist wie
stabil ist die Ukraine wie weit ist sie
auch demokratisch und deswegen hat man
dann sehr deutlich gesagt es gibt diese
Nate beitrittsgarantie nicht und das hat
dann seine akzeptiert und dann hatte ein
bisschen Kreide gefressen wie wir
gesehen haben und dann kommt dieser
offizielle ottung zustande dass er
zufrieden ist aber er ist nicht
zufrieden er ist eigentlich sauer
womit silensky aber nach Hause geht das
ist diese Sicherheitsgarantie der G7
kannst du uns da noch mal kurz abholen
was bedeutet das genau und wie zufrieden
ist er damit
also wie man immer so schön sagt so ein
gipfad Licht und Schatten aber den
Schatten gesprochen jetzt über die Dinge
die positiv für den selensky sind er hat
noch mal sehr viel zu sicheren bekommen
an militärisch Unterstützung von den
deutschen allein 700 Millionen und er
hat dieses sogenannten
sicherheitszusagen bekommen von den G7
Staaten und das heißt man will jetzt
dauerhaft quasi die Waffenlieferung
einrichten es soll nicht mehr jedes Mal
lange diskutiert werden man hat ja
gesehen am Anfang des Krieges hat es
doch sehr lange gedauert bis die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine angelaufen
ist und das soll jetzt nicht mehr
passieren es soll ein Automatismus geben
das ist ein großer Erfolg für ihn obwohl
man auch ein bisschen sagen muss wenn
man ein bisschen zwischen die Zeilen
liest sind das erstmal sehr starke Worte
von diesem
Kommunikatoren wie das dann aussieht
wenn es Wirklichkeit werden wird wird
man sehen weil diese Verträge die
dauerhaft dann Waffenlieferung an die
Ukraine sichern sollen die müssen jetzt
mit Ausländern abgeschlossen werden und
dann wird man sehen wie sehr die Länder
dann dazu stehen
ja Thema starke Worte ich habe hier
gerade noch eine Frage im Job gesehen wo
ein User auch fragt könnte schon die
Erwähnung dass die Ukraine in die NATO
eingeladen werden könnte was ja wie wir
jetzt wissen auf dem Gipfel gar nicht
passiert ist Russland noch aggressiver
machen also ist diese Angst vor Russland
auch ein Motiv dafür die NATO bisher
nicht in die Ukraine einzuladen
ich glaube das nicht weil man ja doch
sehr klar gemacht hat ist dass dieser
nato-beitrag wenn er stattfindet erst
stattfindet nach einem Ende also nach
Kriegsende weil sonst wenn die NATO
jetzt quasi wenn die Ukraine jetzt
beitreten würde dann würde dieser
berühmte Artikel 5 ziehen dann hätte man
den Bündnisfall und dann müssten alle
die Ukraine verteidigen und dann wäre
die ganze Welt im Krieg das wird es
nicht geben ich glaube das ist
drocolisten die Putin immer wieder gerne
aufbaut er hat ja auch gesagt dass er
wenn Schweden aufgenommen wird und
Finnland aufgenommen wird dass er dann
wirklich aggressiver wird und beide
Länder Finnland ist aufgenommen und
Schweden wird wohl aufgenommen die NATO
man hat das trotzdem gemacht als man
lässt sich da von Putin nicht
einschüchtern ich glaube wirklich dass
man diese Garantien nicht gegeben hat
gerade von Seiten Amerika weil man sie
nicht geben wollte weil man sich so
nicht festlegen wollte
ich danke dir für diese Eindrücke vom
letzten Tag des Nato-Gipfels und wünsche
alles Gute nach Vilnius
alles Gute zurück nach Mainz
ja und über diese G7 Sicherheitsgarantie
über militärische Unterstützung aber
auch über die Lage in der Ukraine an der
Front möchten wir noch mal sprechen und
zwar weiterhin mit dem ehemaligen
us-generalleutnant bin hat es gut
evening müsste Hodges da ist er
und ähm wir möchten einmal über diese
Ankündigung der G7 Staaten sprechen die
haben ja heute gesagt Sie wollen die
Ukraine jetzt mit der Lieferung moderner
Ausrüstung für ihre Luft und
Seestreitkräfte
unterstützen und das neue an diesem
Papier ist ja auch die ähm eine
langfristige strategische Einbettung
dazu würde ich ihn gerne mal einen o Ton
von Kanzler Scholz zeigen die Zeiten
sind herausfordernd Russlands Überfall
auf die Ukraine dauert nun schon mehr
als 500 Tage russland hat damit nicht
nur seine seinen Nachbarn angegriffen
sondern die gesamte europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur gefährdet und
darauf muss auch die atlantische Allianz
eine Antwort geben
der NATO-Gipfel gestern und heute hier
in Vilnius hat diese Antwort sehr klar
formuliert denn hat die NATO gestärkt
unsere Bereitschaft zur Verteidigung
unterstrichen und den Zusammenhalt in
der Allianz erhöht die NATO ist ein
Verteidigungsbündnis des niemanden
bedroht sie ist aber bereit und in der
Lage jeder militärischen Bedrohung zu
begegnen
ja für Kanzler Scholz ist dieser Gipfel
also ein großer Erfolg wie groß ist denn
der Erfolg für selenski der jetzt mit
diesem G7
Sicherheitsversprechen nach Hause fährt
also es gibt zwei oder drei Punkte die
man klar haben muss erstmal gibt es
keine Sicherheitsgarantie außer
innerhalb der NATO die Erklärung der G7
oder versprechen anderer Länder wenn das
kein Vertrag ist dann gibt es auch keine
Garantie die G7 Erklärung ist natürlich
wichtig denn die G7 Länder und deren
Führer haben öffentlich gesagt was Sie
noch tun werden also sie haben das jetzt
öffentlich gemacht sie haben gesagt wir
werden die Ukraine unterstützen mit den
Fähigkeiten aber es ist wichtig dass
nicht zu verwechseln mit einer
tatsächlichen Sicherheitsgarantie und es
ist wichtig dass jedem klar ist dass
eine Einladung an die Ukraine der Natur
zu treten nicht das gleiche ist wie ein
sofortiger Konflikt mit Russland nur
wenn die
Ukraine in der Natur ist dann tritt der
Artikel 5 in Kraft und Schweden sind vor
über einem Jahr eingeladen worden aber
sie sind noch nicht beigetreten also es
geht noch nicht diese Verpflichtung
Schweden zu verteidigen also jeder muss
sich das klar machen
Präsident selenski und ja wie der
Reporter aus willenlos auch sagte ist
ein Profi
musste gestern sehr starke Erklärungen
Abgeber bei musste heute auch zeigen
dass er ein Staatsmann ist und er hat so
viel bekommen wir kriegen konnte positiv
gesehen ist es so dass die Intensität
die das Niveau der Unterstützung und die
Konversation die es in den letzten
Monaten gegeben haben die haben ein
Niveau erreicht dass wir vorher noch nie
erreicht hatten auch die Amerikaner sind
erstaunt wie stark die Unterstützung der
Ukraine innerhalb des Bündnisses
insgesamt ist also meiner Meinung nach
denke ich dass der Vilnius Gipfeln eine
Brücke ist für den Gipfel im nächsten
Jahr zum 75 Jahrestag in washing ich
glaube da wird passieren
vinius als Brücke aber wenn ich sie
gerade richtig verstanden habe dann
sagen sie eigentlich es gibt keine
Sicherheitsgarantie außer den wirklich
NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine oder
ja das stimmt
man hat natürlich auch in Russland auf
diese Ankündigung und auch diesen Gipfel
heute reagiert und dazu haben wir eine
Äußerung von Creme Sprecher pekkopf
mitgebracht
wir halten die Entscheidung der Ukraine
Sicherheitsgarantien zu geben für
äußerst falsch und potenziell sehr
gefährlich da diese Länder durch die
Gewährung jeglicher Sicherheitsgarantien
für die Ukraine die internationalen
Grundsätze der unteilbaren Sicherheit
ignorieren das heißt indem sie der
Ukraine Sicherheitsgarantien gewähren
greifen sie in die Sicherheit Russlands
ein dies ist unmöglich und hat mittel
und langfristig und sogar kurzfristig
sehr sehr negative Folgen
ja also in Russland wird dieser Gipfel
oder die Ergebnisse dieses Gipfels sehr
wohl als sicher als Garantie für die
Ukraine aufgefasst wie bewerten sie denn
diese Äußerungen aus Russland heute
und andere im Kreml haben natürlich
schon lange Zeit über Märchen erzählt
und versuchen das zu verdrehen was
tatsächlich passiert die verdrehen die
Dinge und sehen sich selber als Opfer
der ganze Krieg startete ja durch die
Entscheidung einer Person Wladimir Putin
sie könnten heute den Krieg beenden
und
die russische Grenze war immer eine
Grenze mit der NATO und es ist ein
Nonsens
dass die USA oder das Bündnis
jetzt darüber sprechen dass die
NATO im Endeffekt die auch keine anderen
würde dass die G7
Sicherheitsversprechen abgegeben haben
und Ausbildung und Übungen Manöver was
was ist daran eine Bedrohung für Ostern
gar nichts
wir müssen jetzt klar machen dass
Russland jedes Mal bei jedem bei allem
was wir der ukanal angeboten haben da
haben die
gedroht Atomwaffen einzusetzen sie haben
auch Drogen ausgesprochen als Schweden
und Finnland eingeladen wurden ja die
Russen haben sogar die Truppen von der
finnischen Grenze abgezogen weil sie dir
so dringend brauchen das sind alles
Äußerungen die kein Mensch wirklich
glauben kann niemand der vernünftig ist
er glaubt diese Erklärungen die
Glaubwürdigkeit Russlands ist wirklich
am Boden und wir sollten
daran denke dass wir unsere Werte
unterstützen sicher Souveränität der
Grenzen Menschenrechte Schutz vor
Kriegsverbrechen Respekt vor internation
vor dem Völkerrecht der Respekt vor den
international organisation darauf
sollten wir uns konzentrieren
ja dieser Schutz und die Verteidigung
der westlichen Werte haben sie gerade
schon angesprochen wie unersetzlich ist
denn das was die Ukraine gerade leistet
für die NATO
ich denke es ist sehr sehr interessant
wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt warum die
NATO geschaffen wurde die Naht wurde
geschaffen um Europa zu schützen vor der
Sowjetunion und später um Europa vor
Russland zu schützen die Ukraine schützt
die jetzt tatsächlich
Europa vor Russland aber es werden nicht
eingeladen in die NATO zu kommen das ist
ein Problematik die gelöst werden muss
und ich würde meinen russischen Freunden
sagen die kommt es denn dass alle Länder
die entweder Teil der Sowjetunion waren
oder teilt das war schon verpacktes
fahren oder Nachbarn von Russland waren
während alte Serie wie kommt es dass die
jetzt Schlange stehen und der NATO
beizutreten was ist das was sie aus
ihrer Erfahrung mit Russland wissen dass
sie ihm das Gefühl gibt dass Ihre
Sicherheit ihr Überleben am besten
geschützt ist wenn sie innerhalb des
erfolgreichsten Verteidigungsbündnis ist
es sind in der Geschichte der Welt denn
die wissen was passiert
wenn russische Truppen das eigene Land
einfallen was er mit dem Menschen
passiert mit der Umwelt passiert und
deswegen ist es so dass die Ukraine so
scharf drauf ist zur NATO beizutreten
ja und wir kommen jetzt mal vom
sozusagen diplomatischen Überbau ein
bisschen mehr ins Detail im Rahmen des
Gipfels hat ja auch Kanzler Scholz ein
neues militärpaket versprochen dass
insgesamt 700 Millionen Dollar stark ist
wie bewerten sie denn dieses neue
militärpaket ist das ein starkes Paket
und was fehlt ihrer Meinung nach
vielleicht
also im Gremmel müssen die
wahrscheinlich jetzt außer sich sind sie
können sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
Deutschland so viel tut und der Ukraine
zu helfen Russland hätte das nie
erwartet dass Deutschland vor tritt und
so eine wichtige und verantwortungsvolle
Rolle für die Verteidigung und
Sicherheit Europas einnimmt Deutschland
ist teilweise der zweitgrößte mach den
zweitgrößten Beitrag so keine ich weiß
nicht ob das andere überhaupt so klar
ist welche wichtige Rolle Deutschland
dabei spielt
dieses letzte Paket über 700 Millionen
das ist ein beträchtlicher Betrag im
Bezug auf Waffen Ausrüstung Munition
dass wir dringend gebraucht in der
Ukraine und ich bin selber Eindruck dass
leoparde Panzer Mörder in da drin sind
und Dinge die wichtig sind um die
um die die die die Bevölkerung in der
Ukraine zu schützen vor den russischen
Waffen was noch fehlt das ist das was
die Ukraine jetzt vor allen Dingen
brauchen und das sind Langstrecken
Präzisionswaffen das torosystem z.B mein
Land
trotz allem was wir geliefert haben wir
haben auch bis jetzt noch nicht die
attackens
Raketen angeboten die 300 Kilometer
Reichweite haben also das fehlt noch im
deutschen Paket und das ist das was auch
vor allen Dingen im amerikan ischen
rüstungspaket fehlt ich weiß nicht warum
ich verstehe es nicht so ganz warum wir
da so zögert sind und natürlich kenne
ich die Gründe aber sie sind nicht
wirklich überzeugend
können Sie uns diese Gründe auf
amerikanischer Seite und deutscher Seite
die ihrer Meinung nach nicht überzeugen
sind noch mal erklären wie argumentieren
die Amerikaner und die Deutschen
ich glaube es gibt so oder drei Gründe
warum die aber egala das so machen wie
sie es machen und ich denke Deutschland
denkt ähnlich
zunächst mal die Regierung beiden trotz
all der guten Dinge diese getan haben
die Regierung beiden hat immer wieder
unterstrichen dass sie alles tun werden
um eine Eskalation mit Russland zu
vermeiden das heißt sie würden nicht
etwas tun was
Langstreckenwaffen liefert
wodurch die Ukraine die Möglichkeit
hätte Ziele in Russland anzugreifen nach
der un-karte hat natürlich das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung und die Ukraine haben
Washington gesagt wir werden die Attack
und Raketen nicht gegen Ziele in
Russland anwenden wenn das nur Bedingung
ist die haben gelogen Ziele innerhalb
der Ukraine die sie anziehen könnten wo
die Russen sich festgesetzt haben
ist glaube ich einer der Gründe der
andere Grund ist dass die Regierung in
Washington sich Sorgen macht das wenn
die Ukraine so einen großen Durchbruch
erzielt den sie erzählen könnte wenn Sie
diese Langstreckenwaffen hätten dann
wäre es möglich die Creme und haltbar zu
machen für die russische Marine in
Sebastopol und unhaltbar für die
russische
Luftwaffe in auf der Krim und das ist
das wo wo die
US-Regierung nicht bereit ist das
akzeptieren und dann gibt es Druck aus
China die Chinesen wollen keine
Situation sehen wo Russland
möglicherweise kollabiert oder das
Russland verliert denn die Chinesen
wollen keinen Zugang zu billigem Erdgas
verlieren und Präsident Chi will auch
nicht dass irgendwas mit dem Präsident
der Russischen Föderation passiert war
das ja auch seine eigene Verletzlichkeit
reflektieren würde ich glaube dass du
die Haupt Gründe
soweit zu den Gründen wir haben gerade
schon die Karte im Anschnitt gesehen und
wir wollen auch jetzt noch mal in die
auf die Lage in der Ukraine an der Front
gucken die meisten Stimmen sagen ja
aktuell diese ukrainische Offensive die
verläuft eher schleppend es werden
kleine Erfolge
verlautbart trotzdem ist der das
generelle der generelle Fortlauf dieser
Offensive eher schleppend wie bewerten
Sie die Lage aktuell und wo hat es ihrer
Meinung nach besonders gerade bei den
Ukrainern
ich denke wir alle würden natürlich
gerne eine offensive sehen die schneller
voranschreitet das würde bedeuten wir
kämen schneller zu einem ukrainischen
Siege und viel weniger Soldaten auf
beiden Seiten hätten
unnötigerweise zu sterben und das ganze
könnte schneller beendet werden wenn die
Vereinigten Staaten und andere Länder
sich darauf verzichten würde dass die
Ukraine gewinnt um und und und wenn sie
der Ukraine alles geben würde was sie
braucht der General starb der Ukraine
hat glaube ich eine gute Arbeit
geleistet die passen sich an die sehen
wie schwierig es ist die russischen
Befestigungen zu durchbrechen und sie
haben sich entschlossen
nicht die eigenen Soldaten in den
Fleischwolf zu schicken wie die Russen
das machen sondern sie
attackieren russische befehlsstände
gestern haben sie mit einer Langstrecken
Rakete einen russischen drei Sterne
general getötet sie greifen die Logistik
der Russen an und die Artilleriestellung
und der Russen und das führt dazu dass
die russische Verteidigung nicht mehr so
effektiv ist wenn man die Logistik die
Artillerie und die befehlsstände
vernichten kann dann ist es so dass die
Verteidigung an der Front viel
verletzbarer wird ich glaube der
Generalstab in der Ukraine macht das
wirklich gut und die
vergeuden nicht das Leben ihrer Soldaten
und die Russen wissen natürlich nicht
genau wo dann die tatsächliche
hauptangriffte Linie stattfinden wird
die meisten organischen Regal sind noch
nicht einmal im Kampf geschehen also man
versucht hier und da mal ein bisschen zu
sondieren wo die Befestigung der Russen
verletzlich sind die richtige
hauptoffiziere kommt erst noch und ich
denke wir müssen wissen
die Ukrainer machen das ohne dass sie
Luftunterstützung haben denn der Westen
liefert noch keine F16 oder moderne
Flugzeuge wir würden nie amerikanische
oder britische Soldaten in so einem
Kampf schicken ohne Luftunterstützung
und das ist überraschend was die Ukraine
hinkriegen ohne die Unterstützung aus
der Luft
ja wir haben hier in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten auch immer wieder darüber
gesprochen wie wichtig eigentlich diese
Luftwaffe wäre und die Lieferung von F16
die diskutieren wir ja auch schon länger
was glauben Sie denn wann sehen wir denn
die ersten F 16 Flugzeuge in der Ukraine
und das ist eine tolle frage
sie können jetzt schon dort pflegen wenn
wir die Entscheidung vor einem Jahr
getroffen hätten die Piloten
entsprechend auszubilden dann wäre das
jetzt an der ganz andere Situation aber
ja so ist das halt ich höre
unterschiedliche Geschichten darüber wie
lange es dauern würde und keinische
Piloten auf der F16 zu äh auszubilden
einer aus der Niederland sagte acht
Monate aber hochrangige ein hochrangiger
amerikanischer ähm
Air Force General der selbst sind F 16
Plus ist der sagte wenn ein ukrainischer
Pilot der schon sehr viele Stunden in
der Luft zugebracht hat ist dann dauert
das seit drei Monate der ukrainische
Pilot der sich auskennt der könnte dann
auch die jetzt 16 fliegen nach drei
Monaten die Ukraine haben uns bis jetzt
immer wieder bei jedem System was wir
ihnen gegeben haben überrascht die
lernen sehr schnell damit umzugehen und
dass wir unterschätzen immer wieder
deren Fähigkeit schnell zu lernen mit
neuen Technologien und Systemen
umzugehen der Ausbildungsteil wenn der
nächste Woche anfangen würde dann würde
man wahrscheinlich über drei bis vier
Monate sprechen und dann hätte man
ukrainische Piloten die
Flugzeuge das eine andere Geschichte wo
kommen die her es gibt eine Reihe von
Nationen
das ist die F16 Gemeinschaft die willens
wäre Unterstützung zu leisten bei der
Ausbildung der Piloten da käme
vielleicht auch die Flugzeuge her aber
dann braucht man natürlich auch die
Wartung die Boden Crews Leute die das
Flugzeug warten können und dann muss man
die entsprechend vorbereiten für den
Kampfeinsatz und diese Ausbildung
braucht man auch ich denke mal das
könnte von entsprechenden
Lohnunternehmern durchgeführt werden
ja wir werden auf jeden Fall darüber
berichten sollte ist soweit sein ja und
dass ich habe zum Schluss noch eine
Frage aus der Community für Sie unsere
Community spricht übrigens ein großes
Lob aus und freut sich sehr dass Sie
hier sind und unsere Fragen beantworten
hier fragt sich noch jemand auf Youtube
was verspricht sich die Ukraine
eigentlich nach dem Beitritt und das
runde die Sendung ja noch mal ganz gut
ab weil wir fragen uns heute fehlt der
NATO aktuell der Mut für diese
Beitrittserklärung aber erstmal was
verspricht sich die Ukraine ganz konkret
von so einem Beitritt der jetzt nach
diesem Gipfel erstmal in die Ferne
gerückt ist
ich würde sagen
obwohl die Naht obwohl die Ukraine jetzt
nicht
diese Einladung an die Ukraine gegeben
hat ich denke doch dass die Ukraine oder
es fühlt sich so an als ob es jetzt eine
signifikante kulturelle Veränderung
gegeben hat eine Bewegung auf der Seite
der das Bündnisses gegenüber der Ukraine
die Dringlichkeit und die Unterstützung
ist auf einem viel höheren Niveau als
jetzt zuvor und man hört immer weniger
Ausreden oder Probleme die angesprochen
werden
all diese alten Konflikt Punkte Schaden
Weg zu sein und präsenzellensky war sehr
intelligent nach Vilnius zu reisen und
dort zu sein das macht es jetzt
schwieriger etwas zu sagen und für ihn
zurückzuweisen wenn er selber dort ist
es war wichtig dass er dort heute war
beim Rad
der bei NATO keine Rat das ist nicht nur
Kosmetik das ist mehr
es ist ein schlechter Tag für den Kreml
wenn Sie sehen dass der Präsident der
Ukraine an einem runden Tisch sitzt mit
den anderen Staats- und Regierungschefs
der NATO ich glaube im nächsten Jahr da
bin ich sehr optimistisch in einem Jahr
von jetzt an wird die Ukraine eingeladen
der im Bündnis beizutreten inzwischen
ist es ganz wichtig der UK keine zu
helfen
Russland zurückzudrängen die
Souveränität herzustellen die tausenden
gekennzeichneten Kinder aus Russland
zurück in die Ukraine zu bringen und ein
nachhaltiger Frieden ähm bedeutet wie
der Präsident aus
Litauen gesagt hat heißt dass diese
Probleme gelöst werden
das ist eine sehr klare Prognose zum
Abschluss dieses Gesprächs mit dem
ehemaligen us-generalordnern hat es
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns
waren einen schönen Abend noch
vielen Dank für das Privileg
ja wir haben es gerade gehört Ben Hodges
sagt in einem Jahr wird die NATO der
Ukraine diesen Beitritt ermöglichen bis
dahin bleiben wir natürlich für euch am
Thema und ich habe jetzt hier noch mal
einen Blick in die Kommentare geworfen
und sehe dass ihr unsere Sendung lobt
hier schreibt jemand beste News Sendung
im ZDF und noch jemand anders schreibt
alles Format großes Lob an das ZDF
vielen dank dieses Lob kann ich
natürlich nur an euch zurückgeben als
Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen ich bedanke
mich bei Euch für die spannenden Fragen
und Kommentare und wünsche euch noch
einen schönen Abend bis dann